[Music]
i'm always seeing you on magazine covers
and you always look beautiful and you
did a magazine photo shoot for a
magazine called com complex magazines
yeah and it was just a very different
shot of you i didn't know you're
beautiful but i didn't quite know what
it is it seemed like a very different
photo shoot for you i think we have the
picture here
it looks like they have a bra and you're
welding or something it's like with big
machines yeah it's one of those things
where they're like we want you to look
really like look empowered and
aggressive and you're like oh and
they're like no but sexy and you're like
ugh
she's trying to figure out i mean don't
they do they they tell you to do weird
things to hold welding guns and look
sexy yeah yeah or my favorite is when
the photographer will be like okay you
have a secret
they're like what is what does that look
like i don't like it when they say be
yourself because i'm like well if i were
myself i probably wouldn't be standing
here in a nice clothes getting
photographed by you so very it's very
weird well i found if you're in comedy
and you show up for any kind of photo
shoot they're always wanting you to do
something wacky and usually the night
before they've had a couple of ideas
and so you show up and it's like we
built a giant toilet
and you're coming out of it holding your
nose and you're like what what they're
like it's crazy wacky
coming out of a toilet why would i want
to do that yeah but i always do
and that's why they keep coming back
yeah you are a uh you're an animal lover
i am do you have a lot of animals i do i
have a dog and a cat
and um that's crazy i know
i know it's not like it's not insane
that's cat is actually uh is a bit of a
con woman though because
she initially tricked me into taking her
off the street by
basically tricking me into thinking she
had cancer she had this big lump on her
stomach pat trick
[Applause]
a very sweet cat in chicago and i i kind
of felt sorry for it it kind of made its
home in my trailer and i was like you
know i don't really like cats so i'll
just take it around see if it belongs to
anyone the local vet came and looked at
it and it was like well it's a sweet cat
but it has cancer just let it like you
know die and i was like no i can't do
that so i'm gonna take the kitty back to
los angeles buy it a first class ticket
really give it give it a good life on
its way out so then it can and it pass
out nicely give it that nice shot yeah
in beverly hills right um we were in
chicago where i found this cat in the
snow and when we got back to um the vet
here in la i brought the cat in and he
was like oh this is a beautiful cat and
i was looked too bad about the cancer
he's like what cancer and i was like you
know the cancer and he's like oh the
hernia i can remove that when i neuter
her and so what not beautiful cat gonna
live 25 years and i was like no
now i have a cat
what's with the crappy vet in chicago
terrible that thing's got cancer let it
die yeah it's terrible right it turns
out the cat's something like just let it
go into nature and i'm like we're in
downtown chicago this is the worst vet
i've ever heard of put it under a tire
and back over it
and now this cat's gonna be with you
forever now forever and what's your dog
like um he's sweet he's a sweet little
dog but he has a very girly name i named
him cinnamon and he's a he's a yorkie oh
he's a he's a dude but you call him
cinnamon but i call them like cinnamon
that doesn't help cinnamon buns like
buns here you are with buns again yeah
not good uh so you call him cinnamon
yeah right is he a manly dog
well i only learned this recently
because i was doing a skype interview
with a journalist and he said you know
show me around your house and on the
laptop and so i kind of held my dog up
to show him and he
told me that he had a very prominent
uh
johnson
the dog very smart penis penis the dog's
penis is quite large it is for his body
he has a large i'm allowed to say that
that's we're allowed to talk about that
stuff yeah big one uh i was very proud
though i'm his mom so yeah
you know
yeah you're proud of that kind of stuff
i guess so it's weird uh
so you held it up and that's just so
weird that the journalist went right i
mean you've had the dog for a while and
then the journalist was like look at the
genitalia yeah
probably looking for a story but yeah
here i gave him one yeah it was for dog
fancy magazine yeah